ich muss wirklich sagen ich kann es kaum
fassen was gerade bei dieser mpk
passiert ich hätte mir nicht erträumen
lassen dass wir hier stehen
es ist jetzt 18 05 es ist der zweite
punkt über den ernsthaft gesprochen wird
in dieser mpk und ist kommt raus dass
wir einfach keine tests haben sie
existieren nicht nele das heißt das was
der was der gesundheitsminister
angekündigt hat ab erster märz das war
das gab ist gar nicht das heißt wir
erleben jetzt dass dort in dieser
ministerpräsidenten konferenz ist geht
ein jahr in dieser pandemie ein jahr
später wird darüber gesprochen eine
taskforce einzusetzen das muss man sich
mal vorstellen
wir werden hier eingeschlossen wir
dürfen und wir sollen unsere kontakte
reduzieren und unsere politiker kriegen
es nicht hin dass schnell konzept
umzusetzen
ich weiß gar nicht mehr mir fehlen die
worte nele mir fehlen wirklich die worte
und es ist auch nicht mehr zu verstehen
was dort hinter verschlossenen türen
passiert und wie es möglich ist dass man
sich die schuld hin und her schiebt der
bund sagt na ja die länder sollen doch
bestellen und dann bestellt am besten
niemand und dann gibt es auch nur ein
angebot aber es gibt nicht genug und es
gibt eigentlich gar nix wenn die schulen
wir öffnen
wir wollen weiter öffnen und anders als
in anderen ländern können wir nichts
testen weil wir keinen schnelltest haben
dann liegt an genehmigungen und jetzt
liegt es auch an den mangelnden
bestellung das ist wirklich man muss
sagen wenn man das vergleicht so
zusammen mit der impfstoff bestelle wo
man noch sagen kann ok ja da war die
europäische union mit beteiligt und am
ende wollten wir dann mit allen
bestellen auch da gibt es nicht so
wirklich eine entschuldigung aber bei
den stellt es war nur deutschland die
deutsche regierung für die schnelltests
bestellung in ihrem land zuständig und
sie sind kolossal gescheitert ist das
jetzt aufgenommen worden vor allem nach
vier stunden wir leben da wären gerade
vom regen das ist ja dass er es ist dann
sagt ist es so dramatisch das kann in
diesem moment wie ich gehört habe die
kanzlerin sich
jens spahn verteidigen musste und hat
gesagt er habe ja nur ein angebot
gemacht für die schnelltests mehr nicht
und die kanzlerin und sparen sie hätten
gar keine erwartungen geweckt sondern
zitat nur ein angebot gemacht hat bei
uns einen haben sie erwartungen damit
geweckt als zehn jahren wurde wurde das
als zentraler baustein beschrieben der
sozusagen in die gesamte öffnungs
perspektive sein sollte es ist ein
kolossales scheitern hier des
bundesgesundheitsministers der kanzlerin
und all denjenigen die mit diesem
schnelltest zu tun haben mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren